tras nueve meses detenido en Israel sala
a Mauri pisará Francia la decisión Del
ministro del interior israelí de
deportarlo se tomó después de que se
revocará la residencia de Mauri hace dos
semanas
hoy el terrorista ha sido expulsado a
Francia tiene nacionalidad francesa y
después de que yo le privara de su
residencia ha sido expulsado en avión a
Francia tolerancia cero con terroristas
que no deberían estar en el país
el abogado Franco palestino está acusado
por Israel de apoyar activamente al
frente popular para la liberación de
Palestina cosa que él siempre ha negado
el pasado mes de marzo fue detenido en
virtud de una orden de aprehensión
administrativa de tres meses que se
renovó desde entonces en 2005 fue
condenado a siete años de prisión por
planear el asesinato del destacado
rabino ovadia Joseph posteriormente fue
puesto en libertad como parte de un
canje de prisioneros con jamás por un
soldado israelí el caso de amauri siento
un presente para las expulsiones de
jerosolimitanos con ciudadanía
alternativa
tu expresión
es la expresión de una especie de
voluntad de sofocar y asfixiar todas las
voces disidentes y no solo la suya en
Israel
según varias ong francesas entre ellas
amnistía internacional la expulsión del
abogado es una expresión del objetivo de
las autoridades israelíes de reducir el
número de palestinos en Jerusalén este